nice how many outfits did you bring um i
i bought too many man i bought too many
outfits
yeah i just want to let everybody know
it's not that i'm that short it's these
shoes down here
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold on hold on can't see him all right
let him get a little peek
let's see just a little peek you lift it
up okay okay just a little peek there's
a little peek at this oh wait wait wait
it won't come up over them
they do not want to be seen oh my god
look at those things
look at those things what are those uh
these are custom made
i have the best dallas of all time named
hodomusa
uh you know she gets it done man yeah
did it trip you out a little bit with
the the all the pushback that came back
with montero and the shoes and all that
was were you like what's going on y'all
just relax i thought it was way more
than i would have believed that it would
be i mean you know but that's
life we got to push it forward we got to
keep going
yeah what does it also mean that we're
here at bet awards and the culture
loves you and you represent something
that had been shunned from the culture
for so long and you were the one who
really
kind of made a difference you made a
huge difference in how we looked
at um
i'm happy to be a part of this change i
know it's going to be a long
a long way to go you know uh but
we're here we're career get used to it
i'm just playing um
but yeah like it's pride month happy
pride month i'm happy to be one of the
stars that can help push this forward
you know within the black community
uh yeah it's it's it's it's a big deal
it's a big deal because you know i see
kids looking at you and saying
i love little i love that guy i love
this oh i love that outfit oh it's cool
and i think that's a big change
it's amazing yeah i'm really thankful to
be
that one who's helping bring that young
14 year old hating himself
you know up in spirit you know yeah that
makes a big difference
all right you're performing tonight tell
me about the performance real quick um
performance i can't give you much but
it's going to be the best one
no offense to all the other performers
that's what everybody says